right so to answer that we first have to
say what we mean by the Big Bang Theory
because this phrase is meant in two very
different contexts right we all know the
universe is expanding so if you run the
clock backwards if you run the film to
the past 14 billion years ago it was in
a hot dense state and we have something
called the Big Bang model of cosmology
which is simply the statement that 14
billion years ago the universe was in a
hot dense state it expanded and cooled
and went from being very smooth to
relatively lumpy which it is right now
with all these stars and galaxies and so
forth that's the Big Bang model it is
true there's no point in doubting the
Big Bang model okay we don't let people
up here on stage if they doubt that part
of the Big Bang model but if you take
seriously general relativity and you say
well what happened at the very beginning
what happens so we know exactly what the
universe was doing one minute after the
very beginning of the Big Bang okay from
one minute after 214 billion years after
we understand that first minute is a
little bit up for grabs so classical
general relativity the theory that
Einstein gave us for space and time
would say according to Roger and Stephen
Hawking that at that moment T equals
zero at the very beginning there was a
singularity but there's also this thing
called quantum mechanics which gets in
the way which is not part of general
relativity so if you want to say the Big
Bang event the Big Bang moment the
beginning of everything we don't know
whether that is right or not we have
room as theoretical physicists and
cosmologists to invent new scenarios and
debate over which is right which is
wrong and so that's where our
disagreement comes in I'm pretty
agnostic to be honest about whether or
not that moment because it's a moment in
time the Big Bang not a place in space
it's not an explosion in a pre-existing
space it's the beginning of everything
it's the moment before which there were
no other moments and that's the model
and the question is is that model right
so I I have two favorite theories and
neither one of them is Rogers favorite
theory so that gives us something to
talk about one theory that I think is
very
at least on the table as plausible is
yes that is the beginning of the
universe and it's because time and space
themselves are not fundamental that when
you get deep into the guts of quantum
mechanics you realize that all the stuff
around us the tables the chairs space
itself time itself are emergent
approximate phenomena they're like
talking about the air as a fluid with
the temperature and a pressure rather
than talking about the molecules maybe
even time is just a good approximation
and it started 14 billion years ago
that's one possibility that I think is
very plausible the other if time is
truly fundamental if time is real and
there and an inextricable from the
fundamental equations then I think it's
very likely that the Big Bang was not
the beginning in that case but I also
think that as Roger has emphasized
better than anyone there's something
very profound about the nature of time
in our observable universe namely that
it has a direction right that the past
is different from the future and if we
can get into this I hope the reason why
the past is different from the future in
your everyday life the reason why you
remember yesterday and not tomorrow is
ultimately because of what conditions
were like at the Big Bang
that's what set up the arrow of time and
that's the fundamental mystery of
cosmology why was it like that so my
favorite view of that is that there is a
much larger universe that we don't see
that our little universe is a tiny
little part of the whole picture and the
whole picture is actually symmetric that
there are people in our past who think
that we are in their past the time runs
in the opposite direction for them as it
does for us this is not by any means set
in stone we don't know it for sure but
these are the kinds of scenarios that
we're talking about as professional
cosmologists to understand why the
universe that we do live in looks the
way it does
you